pecker vajayjay Johnson badge dawn
sausage wallet
[Music]
I don't know about you but something in
between my legs go jiggling around while
I'm running not so comfortable I've
never had a problem exercising with a
penis like everything is contained and
inside and then when you're done you
have no chasing what about frontal
wedgies camel toe is a thing it's not
uncomfortable it's just uncomfortable
for everyone else if I have to go to the
bathroom lines are shorter if there is a
line go out to the bushes the world is
our toilet I can go wherever I want as
long as it's not a playground with kids
playing on it when you decide to go in
the stall everyone knows that you're
pooping that's the one that you'll get
though congratulations it's easier for
you to piss that's a lot I do that every
day as a man very easy give me two
minutes an internet connection and I can
get that [ __ ] done vaginas can have
multiple orgasms 36 percent of time
women do not have an orgasm 36 percent
of the time that women have orgasms it
lasts a lot longer than men's
orgasms are awesome we all know that
honestly in sex everyone's the winner
[Music]
penises are very easy to clean
washcloths in 30 seconds in the shower
you were good to go
a vagina is like a cat it cleans itself
penises you have to clean around the
foreskin and hip area we don't have to
get surgery to keep ours clean well
she's a girl she's good to go she can go
periods are gross
[Music]
you know we've had a lot of fun here
today some fighting words exchanged all
people are indebted to the vagina in one
way or another we are also indebted to
the penis I think we can all agree on
that let's go grab some tacos okay